part of being an accountability group is
that we hold elected officials
accountable for their promises obviously
we are incredibly supportive of the work
that the Biden Administration does but
part of being a good friend is holding
your friends accountable as much as you
hold your opponents accountable so that
clock is just a reminder to President
Biden that he made this pledge and we
look forward to him making good on that
promise as soon as possible the
parallels between Bears ears and the
vicome certainly that these are both
tribally LED National Monument proposals
and the Obama Administration in the case
of bears ears and now the Biden
Administration in the case of avikume
showing that they take tribal
consultation seriously and that the
government to government consultation
process that takes place uh involving a
national monument that is being
requested by indigenous Nations is so
Central to that process and it has been
been wonderful to see that take place
under the the Biden Administration the
the legacy of President Obama's national
monuments I think now that we are five
six years out from from gold Butte and
from Basin and Range you're really
seeing what happens as public lands
settle in to to the consciousness of
what a National Monument is and you're
seeing the Bureau of Land Management
moving ahead now uh at Gold Butte with
plans to to improve that you're seeing
Michael heiser's amazing sculpture City
uh open up at Basin and Range and I
think it really is wonderful to see what
happens over just a few years after
public lands are protected and how they
really become Central especially to
rural economies and Gateway communities
and Nevada I think is a really shining
example of that right now